you love everything about comic-con the
superheroes the cosplay be awesome lines
but now there's a new convention that
has all that - the superheroes and the
cosplay it's line convention line super
fans from the moment you arrive you'll
be greeted with a check-in line then
aligned to collect your badge then
another line to get a program schedule a
line for your gift bag and I want to get
on the escalators which will take you to
the convention floor where you can wait
in over 300 other lives we hire TSA
officers to guarantee wait times of four
hours and up or buy our VIP package and
receive a not so fast pass that sends
you directly to the back of every line
sign up for a workshop and learn classic
line standing techniques straight lines
curvy line lines with weird breaks in
them people who don't know where the
line starts or catch a panel with people
look waited in line for Hamilton looks
real not every pair of New Jordans and a
keynote event er of the butterfly chair
plus celebrity meet-and-greet with famed
British line master dr. Q don't get your
panties wet
there's only one restroom and the line
for it is huge
Russ be sure to stay for the closing
night party where we'll create the
world's largest human in the line to pee
it's rank on the tickets go on sale
undefined warming
[Applause]
you